we're d continuing our declutter power
hour
with a look at how you can declutter
your digital life
i recently heard the quote there are
only two industries
that refer to their customers as users
illegal drugs
and software that's by edward tufte
by the way it's okay if you hear that
noise that's the cousers putting their
shell together
trying to win five grand by the end of
the show
um okay so we have an expert to tell us
more
you can see him on the social dilemma
which i watched on netflix last night
it's incredible and if you haven't seen
it you're going to want to strap in he's
a tech reformer who wants to realign
our technology with humanity people say
he's the conscience
of silicon valley tristan harris is here
hello tristan hi it's so good to be with
you
oh my gosh okay i love your documentary
i love it uh it's like a mockumentary
documentary
it has dramatizations but when you guys
are really talking about
everything with tech i finished the
documentary
i picked up my phone sid do you have my
phone um
and i went and decluttered everything
thank you
okay so this is my phone that's thank
you sid
i love you if i wasn't for sydney where
tomorrow i would be a pile of dust
so that's it and then when i go up
you don't even understand tristan what
it looked like i found out that my
daughters have downloaded like 87
different apps to play on and started
like these weird uh subscriptions
i need to change all my passwords but i
went to bed last night tristan thanks to
you
with peace i didn't know i wasn't
supposed to have notifications on
tristan
what are we doing wrong with simply our
phones let's start there
yeah well i think you know um there's a
difference between being against
technology versus being against a
business model
where you know if you ask someone or
your kids you know how much have you
paid for your instagram account you know
in the last you know year
and the answer is nothing but their
stock price is worth 750 billion dollars
of market value
uh it's because they're selling our
attention in other words our minds our
behavior
our predictability is the product that's
being sold
and so i think that's when people feel
this pull that the truth behind the
screen
is that there's a thousand engineers who
have different goals than our goals who
are trying to figure out how to keep us
scrolling and clicking
from those little red dots those
notifications that keep us coming back
to playing the slot machine and say do i
have more things tell me though like i
put my stuff in folders i got rid of a
ton of stuff
i i now i need to turn off my
notifications i didn't know about this
yeah the first thing people can do is
turn off all notifications most times a
company when you see those notifications
they're trying to invent reasons to get
you to come back like a digital drug
lord kind of like don't you want a
little bit more so
tristan i'm literally i mean it's true
users are what drug dealers call as well
as tech
tristan how old are you i'm 36.
okay so in the 90s and like
in the arts people were really like you
know
had a whole stigma about letting your
kids watch
tv doesn't that seem like the good old
days now
yeah it really does i mean because the
the way that these things are demanding
our moment-to-moment attention
we wake up with these devices we check
them 80 times a day in the bathroom
going to bed at night and so um you know
really people should be really conscious
about what's really worth our attention
i mean i cannot love and promote your
documentary more
it i just met with the marie condo the
the queen of my life
and your documentary which everybody if
they haven't seen it already needs to go
watch it because
it motivated me and completely made me
reorganize my life
and i love that you're the conscience of
silicon valley and getting to know you
as a person
through this documentary i have to say i
really admire you
is there a way we could do this again on
this show too like i need more tristan
in my life
let's do it again
[Music]